it's a place to sleep a place to rest
but not a place you'd call home
for natalia bakova her husband and their
three children this railway carriage and
what's in it is all they have left in
the world their home in the outskirts of
cave was destroyed in the russian
advance gone in just seconds
now 30 families are housed here on
railway carriages somewhere safe
somewhere they can call their own
we don't have anywhere else to go it's
either here or we live on the streets
they have their memories and a few
videos on the phone of happier times
they've been back but just once the
scene too painful the reality too harsh
the children don't understand what's
going on or what's happening it's very
difficult to explain what happened they
think we are on a train so we're going
on a small journey they keep asking when
we will go home
ukraine needs help rebuilding vital
infrastructure like bridges and water
supplies have gone some of the work has
already started the reconstructing this
road on the way to keeve it was blown
apart by the ukrainians to stop the
russian advance on the capital but the
total sum could top more than 750
billion dollars
it was president zielinski told the
donors conference in switzerland
a colossal job
ukrainian forces have liberated more
than a thousand settlements from the
occupiers and new ones are added every
week
all of them suffer a significant
destruction and this is also implies the
need for colossal funds for the
restoration of infrastructure for the
return of medicines and social service
for the restoration of normal economic
life
this was natalia's home destroyed like
thousands tens of thousands of others so
many people left the country in the
early days of the war that when they
return they'll face scenes like this and
the government wants to rebuild those
homes and with it the lives of millions
alan fisher al jazeera erpin ukraine